'Twas the week before Christmas and all around town
b-ball fans were dying to watch
LeBron, Steph, and Russell throw down.
You should bring back the short shorts. Who wears short shorts? I do. I wear short shorts.
A basketball miracle right here on Christmas Day
stuffed into our stockings by the jolly NBA.
Join us for games, ooh, and something else cool
in between all the dunks a sneak peek of Deadpool.
We hope you've been nice.
See you on Christmas, boys and girls.
Who are you talking to?
Mmm. Oh, that's good.
Hi. Deadpool here with an important public
service announcement. This is your brain.
Actually it's a chimichanga but I'm
making a point because this
is your brain on IMAX.
Bigger is better, right?
Cue the music.
Ah!
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie.
Happy 12 Days of Deadpool.
So this new teaser is all about him just
dropping poo on people's doorsteps, hanging
out with Weasel, dropping NBA teasers. If you guys didn't know, so, like, let's do a quick breakdown of that.
This is mostly going to be Deadpool funny
moments but, like, the really important
information is that even if you
don't watch ESPN, there's a new Deadpool
trailer, like a full trailer coming Christmas
Day. It's gonna come pretty much in the
middle of the day, like in the middle of
the NBA game. You might be asking
yourself why are they dropping it in the
middle of the NBA game? It's really just an
eyeball thing, like they want everybody
that doesn't normally watch Deadpool
content to see it, so they're just shoving it in front of
as many eyeballs as possible. They did the
same thing with one of the Star Wars
trailers. Do not worry, I will totally do
a video for it comes. I mean if you're
subscribed you will totally see it in
your feed. And important stuff, more
Deadpool funny moments. So enjoy this
montage and remember why Deadpool is
one of the best comic book characters.
So important stuff. There is a Deadpool teaser coming tomorrow and then there's gonna be a full trailer
coming on Christmas Day. So whole bunch of Deadpool stuff this week in between Star Wars videos.
I'll be doing a lot more Star Wars the next
couple of days too. While you guys wait for
all that stuff to post, you can click here for
all my Star Wars Episode 7 videos and
you can click here for all my Deadpool
videos. Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.